insgesamt großartige spiele leider oft
wie wir hier sehen vor leeren rängen und
zwar aus gründen es ist nämlich erstens
saukalt und die tickets kosten ein
vermögen olympia erhalt dabei sollten
schöne bilder doch alle ioc skandal
überdecken das war der plan
zum beispiel die sache mit dem
russischen staatsduma ja nur mal zur
erinnerung
man vergisst so schnell zur erinnerung
die russen haben über jahre gedopt und
zwar organisiert von geheimdienst und
polizei zeigen bis heute 0
unrechtsbewusstsein in dieser sache und
dürfen trotzdem mit ihren noch nicht
überführten sportler in südkorea
antreten
nur halt und das war die strafe und
einem völlig anderen namen diese
sauberen athleten werden in einzel oder
mannschaftswettbewerben unter dem namen
olympische athlet aus russland
teilnehmer neben dass russen ja ja ist
jetzt nicht mehr russische athleten
sondern athleten aus russland das habt
ihr jetzt davon
ja man kann nur mutmaßen aber unser
deutscher ioc-präsident der bach wollte
sich halt wahrscheinlich nicht verderben
mit seinem buddy putin natürlich wird
weiter gedopt wissen sie wie zum
beispiel langlauf ohne doping aussieht
hier wie bei unserer kanzlerin das will
doch keiner sehen
das ist nicht telegen übrigens der
präsident des sportgerichts cas das
dopingvergehen ahnten soll ist
gleichzeitig ioc mitglied immer gut wenn
man sich selber kontrolliert da brauchst
du keine kontrolle von außen man redet
sicherlich über alles was sie innerhalb
der familie passiert ist auch normal
aber das redet man innerhalb der familie
mann in der familie
inzwischen gibt es mehr als nur
verdachtsmomente dass die spiele in rio
und tokio gekauft sind gab schon
verhaftung wenn die sportler wenigstens
ordentlich mitverdienen würden bei
dieser gigantische geldmaschine
aber die sportler müssen sich dann
teilweise selber finanzieren auf dem weg
zu olympia
wer zur hölle stützt so ein krankes
system und zeit auch noch hunderte
millionen für übertragungsrechte wer
die eurosport ständig